The chat is too fast.
Oh, jeez.
Hi!
Hello!
Why?
Nimi!
Nimi, I was just watching you.
Thank you.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you so much for the raid, though, right?
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you for all the gifted and the donors and everything.
Holy cow.
Holy cow!
It's been... It's been... It's been... Five years!
Happy Anniversary!
Thank you, Nimi!
Actually, I was like... I had... I was watching you dance.
You're so cute.
And I was like, I can't... Even before I was watching it, I was like, I kind of want to sing Love Fool.
Dedicate to my Oshi Nimi nightmare.
So I kind of have a little bit of a set list, but not really.
Just kind of sing whatever I want.
Thank you, guys!
Thank you so much.
Thank you!
It's been a while since I've done karaoke, so I wanted to do some karaoke today.
And... I wanted to... Um...
Uh... I have an announcement!
I have an announcement!
That will be after ten songs!
So we'll get through ten songs, and then I will do the announcement.
And then we'll see how I'm feeling.
If I can sing some more.
And then we will maybe sing some more.
Um...
Uh...
What else?
I also... There was...
There was one thing I also wanted to watch together.
Or...
Less of a watch, more of a listen.
Um...
Maybe we'll do that after five songs.
Oh my gosh, someone...
The chat is great!
Thank you, guys!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
Um...
So...
Something a little...
A little...
Because last year, I watched my...
I re-watched my...
My...
Uh...
Not debut...
Well, we did watch my debut a little bit, but my...
Debut video that I put out...
Kami, thank you!
And...
But this year, I have something...
A little...
Interesting...
Maybe for you guys...
That...
Um...
Maybe...
You guys would be like...
What?
Huh?
What is this?
We get to hear this?
So...
Yeah, yeah, yeah...
If you wanted to see my...
Reaction to my debut video...
You can...
Watch...
My...
Uh...
Anniversary stream from last year!
But don't go yet!
What?
Obviously...
We're here to sing!
And...
Um...
Yeah!
Oh golly...
I'll put you guys...
On the other side...
Actually, you know what?
I'm gonna do this so I can...
Oop...
My computer is lagging...
Oh gosh...
My computer is lagging!
Okay...
I do wanna also mention...
Um...
Uh...
I don't...
I...
Um...
Unfortunately...
Uh...
This...
The stream is kind of all I got...
Um...
The announcement...
We'll...
You'll see...
I'll see...
I'll explain later...
But also...
N of want to say...
Um...
Uh...
I wanted to...
I don't have like...
Any merch or anything...
So...
Um...
I don't have any merch or anything...
So...
You can...
Rest easy on that...
Um...
But!!!
But I was like...
Hmm...
Maybe I could...
I- Put this kind of thing out for a while now...
And, um, uh, so, uh, at, uh, in one hour, about in one hour, the, uh, I will be releasing custom voice packs.
Custom voice packs limited to 100.
Limited to 100.
So, uh, but it won't be, you know, the last time I do it, obviously.
Um, uh, so, um, yes.
Um, I, if, if, if they sell out, I will do more in the future.
Um, so, um, you know, towards the hour, I will, uh, we will, we will stop for that.
Um, I was, I, everything was, like, not everything, but it was, like, being handled.
And then, um, and then, uh, um, what do you mean, if, you don't, you don't even know the price yet.
You haven't seen the price.
Some people might be, like, oh, I want that.
And then see the price and be, like, oh, not worth it.
The price is, the price, they are, they are $50.
So, it's pretty pricey for just, just me talking, no?
Yeah, so, um, then I, um, I went, I was, like, oh, I really wanted to have this.
I really wanted to do this.
So, I, I, um, I, uh, went to Mosso today.
I was, like, Mosso!
Mosso, I know it's kind of crazy, but can you put this together?
In, like, seven hours.
Small price to pay for Minto voice pack.
Custom voice pack.
So, obviously, obviously, it's, like, safe for work.
And, um, you know, uh, uh, I could, I, it could be that, could be that, um, your, you, what you send is not, not, um, okay for me to say.
And so, maybe that you get something that says, hey, that's not okay.
You need to redo.
But, what do you mean charge more?
Or is it not, it's already so much, no?
I think.
But, you can have me do ASMR, or custom, or you could have me do, uh, scenario, or you could have me create your, uh, custom, uh, alarm clock, or...
I charge 69.
Of course you did, Doki.
Hold on, I'm gonna mod you before I forget.
Well, if you come to Mint Phantom Channel, you'll get it cheaper than Doki Birch.
Be a thousand dollars, no way.
But, yeah, so, um, yeah.
Yeah, I really wanted to do them.
So, uh, think, be thinking.
Be thinking.
If you want to try and get one, um, in about 45 minutes.
That's why I told you guys early.
Oh, gosh.
It's been so long since I've sung.
I'm scared.
I'm nervous.
I hope that my voice holds out.
Doki only charge 69 because we tried making her up the price to 100 during stream.
She also started at 50 bucks like you.
It's because...
I don't know why you guys want to pay more money.
Why do you want to pay more money?
It doesn't make any sense to me.
Actually.
But, I could, you know, like I said, it won't be the last time I do it.
I could, if, if I don't get so tired from doing them, I could do it, like, you know, in a couple months as well.
For those who want to try.
Yes.
Make it $69.
And one cent.
So, yeah.
Five years.
I was gone for a couple of those years.
I apologize.
Maybe it's...
Maybe it's not fair for me to celebrate five years.
But I don't care.
I don't care.
$69.69.
Okay, that's what you will price next time, Doki.
I can celebrate five years if I want to.
It's been five years, so...
It's fair?
Five years is five years.
Exactly.
So, I don't care.
Oh, gosh.
A lot has happened, huh?
Um...
I'm not gonna lie.
I was, like, thinking of songs to sing.
And...
I was like, I'm gonna...
They all ended up being, like, really depressing.
Because it was, like...
It was, like...
Oh...
You know how, like, you want to sing sometimes?
How you feel?
So...
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you, guys, for...
The super chance.
Thank you, bro.
Guys, super, thank you.
Even if you don't want us...
Don't want us to acknowledge how good...
You please mentally assign us as insane.
Yeah, you guys are insane.
That's okay.
Something...
What is it?
Like...
Streamer?
Chat?
Um...
Yeah.
So...
And, guys!
Oh, my gosh.
We are only 10K away...
From 400K?
That's exciting.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Wowie, wowie.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my...
Oh, yay!
Yippee!
Only 10K more!
400K.
Hope everything starts getting better...
And going your way soon.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you for all that you do.
Thank you.
You guys are...
Should we sing?
Let's sing.
Let's sing before I get too nervous about it.
I'm like...
I'm starting to shake a little bit.
I'm nervous.
I'm so nervous.
Oh, I see.
I thank you so much, you guys, as well for the donors in Streamlabs.
I do see them.
But I think they're going to be lost in the sauce for a minute.
From all the Super Chats and members and stuff.
But what I am going to do is let me turn off the sound for those.
Because I am viewing them.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Where should we start with?
Oh, wait.
I want to start.
I think I know.
Oh, alert box.
Give me one moment to turn off...
The sound.
I apologize.
Huh?
Wait.
Do I have to do each one?
Let me...
Okay.
I think so.
Save setting.
I'll readjust these later.
I should probably write down what they were at, but...
Whatever.
Save setting.
Oh, that's why it was so loud.
Minky, minky, minky, minky.
Save setting.
Okay.
Nervous.
Wait.
Sorry.
Hold on.
Oh, that's why.
I was like, huh.
There's no space.
Okay.
I've never sung this song before.
But this one's for my Oshin.
Who's very cute and dances.
She dances well, of course.
But it was also so cute and silly.
Okay.
Dear, I fear we're facing a problem.
You love me no longer, I know.
And maybe there is nothing that I can do to make you do.
Mama tells me I shouldn't bother.
That I ought to stick to another man.
A man that surely deserves me.
I, I think you do.
So, I cry.
Love me, love me.
Say that you love me.
Fool me, fool me.
Go on and fool me.
Love me, love me.
Pretend that you love me.
Leave me, leave me.
Just say that you need me.
Oh.
And I beg for you to love me, love me.
Say that you love me.
Leave me, leave me.
Just say that you need me.
I can't care about anything but you.
Lately I have desperately pondered Spent my nights awake and I wonder What I could have done in another way To make you stay Reason will not lead to solution I will end up lost in confusion I don't care if you really care, as long as you don't go.
So I cry, I pray and I beg.
Love me, love me, say that you love me.
Fool me, fool me, just go on and fool me.
Love me, love me, pretend that you love me.
Leave me, leave me, just say that you need me.
So I cry, and I beg for you too.
Love me, love me, say that you love me.
Leave me, leave me, just say that you need me.
I can't care about anything but you.
Love me, love me, say that you love me.
Fool me, fool me, just go on and fool me.
Love me, love me, I know that you need me.
I can't care about anything but you.
Love me, love me, say that you love me.
Hey,
dramatic zoom.
Why is it, why is it here?
Hello?
Yay!
I, wait.
Oh, la-la-la-la.
Love?
That was my ending fairy.
Little wink.
Wait, hold on.
You know when it gets all close and like...
After a performance.
Wait, it's lingering too long.
I'm getting embarrassed.
Yay!
Yeah, yeah, first song down.
Okay.
That was a good...
That was a good, that was a good warm-up.
Selfishly sending this so I can enjoy my favorite mug again.
Wait, what do you mean favorite mug?
Some people were asking for me to re-release the mugs.
I can try.
I can try, I can try.
There's been a lot, it's been...
It's been actually like so...
So overwhelming because it's been...
It's been...
Like...
Oh gosh.
So, so many people have been reaching out about...
About, you know, the idol group.
And about, you know, if I still wanted to join an agency or anything.
And about...
My merch.
And I posted on Twitter like a prototype of something that...
Uh...
I was like, oh...
Sucks that this won't be made now.
But I got so many people being like...
Do you, do you need help?
Do you...
So I'm...
It's been really...
Overwhelming.
Sorry, I'm trying not to cry.
But in a good way.
Because so many people have reached out.
And...
It's really nice.
Okay.
So...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So many, so many, so many of my friends.
I'm really grateful.
What should I sing next?
Oh wait!
Actually, I heard this one.
On Nimi's stream too.
Sorry.
I'm so obsessed with her.
I hope she's not still here.
This one.
I heard too.
She's into superstitions.
Black cats and voodoo dolls.
I feel a premonition.
That girl's gonna make me fall.
She's into new sensations.
New kicks in the candlelight.
She's got a new addiction.
For everyday and night.
She'll make you take your clothes off.
And go dancing in the rain.
She'll make you live your crazy life.
But she'll take away your pain.
Like a bullet to your brain.
Come on!
Upside, inside, out.
She's living la vida loca.
She'll push and pull you down.
Living la vida loca.
Her lips are devil red.
And her skin's the color of mocha.
She will wear you out.
Living la vida loca.
Woke up in New York City in a funky cheap hotel.
She took my heart and she took my money.
She must have sent me a sleeping pill.
She never drinks the water, makes you order French champagne.
Once you've had a taste of her, you'll never be the same.
Yeah, she'll make you go insane.
Upside, inside, out.
She's living la vida loca.
She'll push and pull you down.
Living la vida loca.
Her lips are devil red and her skin's the color of mocha.
She will wear you out.
Living la vida loca.
She's living la vida loca.
She'll make you take your clothes off and go dancing in the rain.
She'll make you live her crazy life.
But she'll take away your pain.
Like a bullet to your brain.
Come on!
Upside, inside, out.
She's living la vida loca.
She'll push and pull you down.
Living la vida loca.
Her lips are devil red and her skin's the color of mocha.
She will wear you out.
Living la vida loca.
She's living la vida loca.
I know this part.
Come on!
Oh,
my ending fairy.
Wait.
Zoom in.
Zoom.
Never mind, I give up.
Bam.
Yeah!
Livin' la vida loca.
The dance actually looks so fun for that.
Once I have my 3D debut, I want to also do...
Just Dance.
It looks fun.
It looks so fun.
Reverb!
Oh!
I forgot.
Okay.
We'll do this one.
This next one's kind of sad, though.
We'll do reverb on this one.
Enhance.
Ah, ah, ah.
Ah!
Oh, it starts immediately.
Hold on.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Chill.
Chill, chill, chill.
How's the audio, by the way?
School bag in hand.
She leaves home in early morning.
Waving goodbye with an absent-minded smile.
I watch her go with the surge of that well-known sadness.
And I have to sit down for a while.
The feeling that I'm losing her forever.
And without really entering the world.
I'm glad whenever I can share her laughter.
The funny little girl.
Slipping through my fingers all the time.
I try to capture every minute.
The feeling in it.
Slipping through my fingers all the time.
Do I really see what's in her mind?
Each time I think.
I'm close to knowing.
She keeps on growing.
Slipping through my fingers all the time.
Sleep in our eyes.
Her and me.
At the breakfast table.
Barely awake.
I let precious time go by.
Then when she's gone.
There's that odd.
Melancholy feeling.
And a sense of guilt I can't deny.
What happened to the wonderful adventures?
The places I had planned to go.
Slipping through my fingers all the time.
For some of that we did.
But most we didn't.
And why?
I just don't know.
Slipping through my fingers all the time.
I try to capture every minute.
The feeling in it.
Slipping through my fingers all the time.
Do I really see what's in her mind?
Each time I think.
I'm close to knowing.
She keeps on growing.
Slipping through my fingers all the time.
Sometimes I wish that I could freeze the picture.
And save it from the funny trace of time.
Slipping through my fingers.
Slipping through my fingers all the time.
School bag in hand.
She leaves home in the early morning.
Waving goodbye.
With an absent-minded smile.
Speaking of ABBA.
Feel this song recently.
I don't wanna talk.
About the things we've gone through.
Though it's hurting me.
Now it's history.
I've played all my cards.
And that's what you've done too.
Nothing more to say.
No more ace to play.
The winner takes it all.
The loser standing small.
Beside the victory.
That's her destiny.
I was in your arms.
Thinking I belonged there.
I figured it made sense.
Building me a fence.
Building me a home.
Thinking I'd be strong there.
But I was a fool.
Playing by the rules.
The gods made throw a dice.
Their minds as cold as ice.
And someone way down here.
Loses someone dear.
The winner takes it all.
The loser has to fall.
It's simple and it's plain.
Why should I complain?
Tell me, does she kiss?
Like I used to kiss you.
Does it feel the same?
When she calls your name.
Somewhere deep inside.
You must know I miss him.
But what can I say?
Rules must be obeyed.
The judges will decide.
The likes of me abide.
Spectators of the show.
Always staying low.
The game is on again.
A lover or a friend.
A big thing or a small.
The winner takes it all.
I don't wanna talk.
If it makes me feel sad.
And I understand.
You've come to shake my hand.
I apologize.
If it makes you feel bad.
Seeing me so tense.
No self confidence.
But you see.
The winner takes it all.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
So the winner takes it all.
And the loser has to fall.
Cold as ice, way down here.
Someone dear, takes it all.
Has to fall.
It seems plain.
Why complain?
Yeah!
Ain't that life?
Or afterlife if it's my situation.
Or ABBA moment.
ABBA moment!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Baby!
Let's see.
What else should we sing?
Hom,
hom, hom!
Thank you, guys!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Let's do one more.
Oh, thank you so much!
For the store's picture plans are snake figurines!
I will!
Melodies of Life.
Oh, you know what?
That's a really good one.
You know I'm a sucker for Final Fantasy music.
I'm not out of songs, by the way, that I want to sing, so...
Melodies of Life.
I'm not exactly taking requests, but...
I just happened to spot that one.
Is this in Nihongo?
Probably.
Actually, wait, what's that other one?
What's...
What's the other...
I can't remember.
What if I DM you my request?
Okay.
I'm scared.
Do it.
DM.
DM, my DMs are open.
Oh my gosh, Mosso just messaged me instead of beefing up the servers.
I don't know it!
I don't know!
Wait.
Let me see if they have it.
On here.
Why is it giving me panic at the disco?
I don't know it!
Oh, wait!
Featured.
It's not on here.
I don't know it.
Okay.
Five Nights at Freddy's.
Oh my gosh, did you guys see the Five Nights at Freddy's 2 trailer?
I agree with everyone asking for...
Eyes on me!
That's the one.
That's the one that I was thinking of.
Sorry, Melodies of Life.
Did you guys see it?
The FNAF 2 trailer?
And actually...
I asked for Discord.
Fine, I will do Discord.
I'll try it.
I don't know it.
Sorry, I was a fake brownie.
Is there even a...
There's gotta be.
Oh, karaoke!
Here we go.
Okay.
This is me singing Discord when I don't know Discord at all.
Okay, here we go.
Oh my god.
It's so loud.
Holy cow.
I'm not a fan of puppeteers, but I...
Wait.
Oh, it's so fast.
Something terrible is going down through the entire town.
Wrecking iron and it's bing, bing.
I can't sit idly...
I can't move at all.
I curse the name.
The worm behind it all.
Discord!
I'm howling at the moon.
And I'm sleeping in the middle of a summer afternoon.
Discord!
Whatever did we do to make...
Do we take our world away?
Discord!
Are we putting your payload or are we stepping stone to take back the throne?
We won't take it anymore, so take your tyranny away!
Oh yeah.
This is for Doki Bird.
This is exactly how she asked me to sing it as well.
I'm fine with changing status quo.
I'm not letting go in the world that we detored apart.
A terrible catastrophe played by a symphony.
What a terrifying work of art.
I can't sit idly.
No, I can't move at all.
I curse the name.
The worm behind it all.
Doki!
I'm howling at the moon.
And sleeping in the middle of a summer afternoon.
Doki!
Whatever did we do to make you take our world away?
Are we your prey alone or are we just stepping stone?
How close am I to the original?
Am I close
at the...
Very
close.
Like 30%.
Doki, I'm howling at the moon.
And I'm sleeping in the middle of a summer afternoon.
Doki!
Whatever did we do to make you take away our world...
Wait.
Oh.
Doki!
Or are we just stepping stone for you to take by the throne?
We won't take it anymore.
So take your tyranny away!
Doki!
Oh, it's over.
Just kidding.
I thought there was another chorus.
That was Discord.
DokiBird version.
So happy for that.
I hope you guys like that.
Check DMs real quick.
Oh, okay.
Why does it sound like werewolf bar mitzvah?
Spooky scary.
Boys becoming men.
Men becoming wolves.
Why does she say...
She said that it sounded like I was singing...
It sounds like werewolf bar mitzvah when I say it.
It literally sounds...
Werewolf bar mitzvah.
Spooky scary.
Thank you.
What a reference.
Maybe, I don't know.
I started singing it.
In my mind, I was channeling Hamlet.
I've never seen Hamlet.
But that's what I was channeling.
Can you vlog DokiBird on Discord real quick, right?
Okay.
I feel like I need to...
Not do a serious song like Eyes on You.
I need to like...
Have a buffer, you know?
Oh, what's another one?
Oh, what's a buffer?
Hold on.
I'm going to put some music back on.
Well, I think...
Oh!
We had 10 minutes.
Oh, okay.
Cool.
10 minutes before...
The...
Custom voice packs go up.
For those who don't know.
I should say again.
Oh, wait.
I have custom voice packs.
That will be on sale.
Mosso box.
The...
There's a link in the description.
Under...
Into Merch.
Area.
And...
Actually, you know what?
I should just post the link.
I should just pin the link.
Um...
One moment, please.
Oh.
My YouTube crashed.
Nope.
Oh gosh.
I think my computer's crashing.
I don't know why.
Some...
Are you guys still here?
Am I crashed?
Oh, you guys are still here.
Okay.
My...
Everything has...
Oh gosh.
YouTube has crashed.
Hold on.
I might just read you guys through OBS.
One moment.
Sorry.
This is taking forever.
Custom voice pack.
Limited to...
100.
For this time.
There we go.
But don't go yet.
Not yet.
K-pop demon hunters.
Oh my gosh.
I tried singing Golden.
That's the only song I know.
But it's...
It's hard.
That song is hard.
Thank tribute to everyone's favorite.
Free smart audiobooks.
I'm really...
I also don't know...
Golden so well.
Like I only know the...
Hold on.
I wonder if they even have it.
Golden.
I feel like they would.
Wait.
They have free?
Oh.
What'd they do?
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
But I don't know like the beginning.
I only know the chorus.
Can I just sing the chorus?
I could try.
Oh gosh.
I don't know the song either.
Wait.
Is there like a lead vocal?
There might be.
Oh it's...
That's Korean.
I can't even read that.
I can't read that.
It's like actual.
I didn't know...
How to believe...
I was the queen that was meant to be.
I lived in two lives.
Tried to play both sides.
But I couldn't find my own place.
I found a problem child.
Cause I got too wild.
That's how I'm getting paid.
Oh gosh.
It's in Korean.
I'm done hiding.
I'm shining.
Like I'm born to be.
We're dreaming hard.
We came so far now.
I believe...
We're going up, up, up.
It's our moment.
You know together we're glowing.
Gonna bring good
voices.
Oh, something in Korean.
Gonna be, gonna be golden.
Oh, I'm done hiding.
Now I'm shining.
Like I'm born to be.
Oh gosh.
I can't hit that note.
I have no fear.
That's who we're born to be.
This song is so hard.
What the hell?
For no reason.
Good guys.
In Korean.
I can't read it.
Just like in the movie?
Wait, does that happen?
Does she not hit the note in the movie too?
That's crazy.
Because it's such a hard song.
And then it's also...
Oh my god.
Like the song is not kind to anybody.
Like, I mean...
Because it goes so deep.
And then it goes so high.
Holy cow.
Watch the movie.
What's it on?
It's on...
I haven't...
You're by Kamiyoshi.
Thank you.
Oh, what's another song?
Actually, it's...
I fear that my voice has...
Not...
I fear...
Rather, I have to train my voice to do high notes again.
It's on Netflix.
Oh, okay.
I fear that I have to retrain my voice to do high notes.
Because...
I've noticed that I...
I...
I think since I had so much damage, it kind of...
Um...
Owl City!
Oh my gosh, wait.
I have another song I'm going to do by Owl City.
Is it okay?
Okay?
Yeah.
So I will...
I will be practicing.
Practicing, practicing.
Wait.
I wonder if there's a karaoke of this.
Oh...
Wait.
Hold on.
I can probably find her on YouTube.
Um...
Maybe this.
Oh.
Hmm?
Uh...
I don't know.
I'll try this one.
Oh god.
The quality is terrible.
Hold on.
Maybe...
This?
Wait, don't...
Isn't there overlapping voices in this song?
Ah, that's fine.
I
opened my eyes, last night, and saw you in the low light, walking down by the bay, on the shore, staring up at the stars that weren't there anymore.
I was feeling the night grow old, and you were looking so cold, like an introvert.
I drew my over shirt, around my arms, and began to shiver violently before you happened to look and see the tunnels all around me, running into the dark underground.
All the subways around, all the subways around, create a great sound, to my motion critique, farewell.
With your ear to a seashell, you can hear the waves, and underwater caves, as if you actually were inside a saltwater room.
Time together isn't ever quite enough, when you and I are alone, I've never felt so at home.
What will it take to make or break this hint of love?
Can you believe that the crew has gone?
They wouldn't let me sign on.
All my islands have sung in the deep, and I can hardly relax or even oversleep.
But I feel warm with your hand in mine.
When we walk along the shoreline, I guess we'll never know, why sparrows love the snow.
We'll turn off all of the lights, and set this ballroom aglow.
But time together isn't ever quite enough,
this hint of love.
Why does it feel so alone?
So tell me, darling, do you wish...
All the time...
Oh, all the time...
This song's hard to sing with one person.
That was...
The Saltwater Room!
By Owl City.
Yes, yes.
Well, we have two minutes until...
Until...
Uh, the custom voice...
Packs drop!
I'll turn music back on.
And...
And, um...
And, uh...
After that, we're gonna watch something.
It's really listen to something.
But, well, watch, listen.
My merch shift, let's go!
Yay!
So hopefully you guys, uh, thought long and hard about...
What you want me to say...
I could say...
Any...
Oh, oh, I just realized the thing is still on.
Sorry.
Uh...
Camera!
Ah!
I could say...
Encouraging words!
Or...
Yeah, MGS memes!
Anything...
That is within...
That is...
Anything asterisk.
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Odoriko!
Okay, add that to the list.
So...
Hmm...
I could...
I could actually do your...
If you're just like...
Uh...
I like Minto, but she's just not enough of a maid.
You could...
Fulfill your maid fantasies!
You know...
Whatever...
Indiana Jones...
Yeah...
Okay...
Oh gosh...
I'm nervous...
Okay...
Five...
Four...
Three...
Two...
Okay...
They should be up!
I'm gonna check too...
Face off out!
Just kidding...
I'm refreshing...
Can we ask her...
Custom voice back...
Of you just...
Badly butchering...
Cheesy pickup lines...
You could ask for that!
Ah...
Why isn't it loading?
Is
it up?
Oh wait...
Okay...
Hold on...
Refresh...
Is...
Oh...
Reload!
They said...
Reloading!
It's up!
Oh...
Yeah...
It does say...
Their voice pack will be delivered via email by August 31st.
So give me...
Give me a little bit of time before...
Before...
Before you get it, so...
Zero!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you so much for that!
For the rainbow, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Woooo!
Mint Phantom...
Voice... Custom Voice Pack!
You don't see it?
Wait, what do you mean you don't see it?
It's the link here!
It's here, the link!
The link...
Huh?
The link?
It's not up!
It...
Wait, I have a different link in the pinned!
No way!
This?
Oh wait!
Oh, the one goes to...
Wait, there you go.
I thought it would be on the regular store page.
I'm sorry!
I didn't realize!
Sorry, sorry!
That was my fault!
Sorry!
Sorry, sorry, sorry!
So yeah!
Um...
Uh...
Yeah, requests may be asked to be changed if not appropriate.
So I will...
We will send you an email or something.
And then...
Please include your request details in your order note.
Sold out!
Maria, you don't have to pay.
I will just send you anything you want me to say.
I'm refreshing again, just in case it's...
Um...
If you missed out...
I will also...
Um...
Oh, I wish to.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No worries about that.
Only do 100...
To get done, everybody.
So I'm sorry!
But, um...
Yeah.
No!
Thank you!
Thank you for buying that custom voice bag.
I'm sorry!
I don't have anything else...
Um...
Uh...
For you guys...
I fear...
I...
You know...
I was fearful that people would...
Send super chats and stuff.
And I...
I have nothing to give back.
So at least even with this...
I do have my...
My...
My voice!
So...
I have my voice!
So I can at least...
Uh...
Talk to you.
And give that...
To you.
So thank you, everybody.
Thank you.
If you did not give one this time...
We will...
There will be another time.
So do not fret.
Do not fret.
Mm-mm-mm.
Yes.
Wow!
I knew!
Love me too!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Should we...
Oh, wait.
I said I wanted to listen to something after this now, right?
So...
So you guys...
Like I said...
I mentioned...
Um...
Earlier this stream that...
That...
Um...
Uh...
Last year...
During...
Anniversary...
We...
Listened to...
Or we...
We watched my debut video and everything.
And...
Uh...
This time...
I have something a little...
Different...
For you all...
Um...
This was recorded...
Let's see...
Uh-uh-uh...
This was recorded...
Oh!
There it is...
Uh...
Wednesday...
April 29th...
2020...
Wait...
Do...
Do you know what date is tomorrow?
Uh-uh-uh...
Um...
This was recorded...
April 29th...
2020...
But you're like...
Minto...
Today is July 24th...
Your debut...
Uh-uh...
I can't believe it!
Oh...
Um...
Uh...
But...
Maybe...
Some people know...
I've talked about this before...
Um...
Uh...
I...
Originally...
Auditioned for HoloLive...
Like...
Myth...
HoloLive, right?
I auditioned...
Way, way back in the day...
But I...
Did not have any streaming experience...
I had a little bit of...
Video experience...
But...
Tiny, tiny bit...
My channel had maybe...
Five people watching...
You know?
Uh-uh-uh...
And, um...
So the first thing...
I did obviously...
Was make...
An audition video!
Uh-uh-uh...
Which...
Was...
Barely a video...
It was a picture...
And...
Because I had nothing!
It was just a picture...
And me talking!
Uh-uh-uh...
So would you guys like to listen to my audition tape?
I had to cut some things out...
I had to cut a few things out...
Just for personal...
You know?
But would you guys like to listen to...
My audition tape for...
HoloLive...
Myth?
I can show you too...
This is...
I even have the image that I used in the background...
Um...
There are some...
You guys might...
Hear a little bit of...
Difference...
In some details...
Do ignore...
Everything that you know now...
Is...
Correct...
Okay?
Okay!
And obviously...
I did listen to this...
Because I had to make sure that there was...
Not...
Uh...
Personal stuff...
But it's still extremely cringe for me to listen to...
So...
You can enjoy my reaction...
And maybe me giving some additional context...
To some...
Stuff as well...
Oh...
Gosh!
This is...
Okay!
This is an actual blast from the past...
Okay, here's the image that I used...
For my...
Um...
Please, once again...
Ignore the inconsistencies...
I was wrong...
I...
I do not know how to count...
Okay?
Okay...
This is what it was the background...
Just that...
That I made that...
Because I had no form...
I was truly just a little wisp...
I was just a wisp...
Back then, you know?
And...
That was the background...
And now we will listen to...
Wait, hold on...
I think I...
Hold on...
Let me double check...
It's...
It's kind of long...
But I think I...
Oh, yeah, yeah...
Okay, okay...
It's about...
Four minutes long...
I cut...
I think it was...
Yeah...
I think I cut about a minute out of it...
But, um...
I told you all to ignore...
Oh, gosh...
I'm so...
Okay...
Oh, here...
Let me write some context on the screen, too...
Um...
Uh...
Mint...
Holo...
Live...
Audition...
2020...
Circa...
Scary...
Oh, gosh...
Okay...
Oh, my gosh...
This is so embarrassing...
Uh...
Where is the...
Oh, here it is...
Um...
Let me...
Oh, sorry...
Sorry, sorry...
Uh...
Outline...
This is so embarrassing...
Holy cow...
But I was like...
This is something maybe a little funny...
That I can show you guys...
Actually, I'm gonna do this...
So, that's...
Bolder...
There we go...
Okay...
Uh...
Let's...
Let's listen...
And obviously...
Oh, let me also say as well...
Um...
Don't take this as like a...
What to do or what not to do...
For an audition or anything...
Because...
I didn't even get a single view...
They did not...
They did not even...
They did not even click on my application...
So...
And...
Um...
Obviously, everybody that joined...
Is absolutely perfect for who they were...
So...
Or who they are...
Um...
Uh...
It's...
It's, you know...
I'm not salty or anything about it...
Which...
When I say that...
It makes me sound like I'm salty...
But...
But no...
No, it's just really funny to...
Go back and listen to this show...
Yeah...
Okie dokie...
I...
I can't...
I can't buy a soup...
I'm so...
Ok...
Here we go...
Hi there...
It's nice to meet you...
My name is Mint...
And I am a forever 20-year-old maid...
Uh...
Some things I really enjoy...
Are anime...
Japanese idols...
Mobagei...
And video games...
Uh...
Mobagei...
Horror...
And spooky things...
I think at that time...
I was really into Dragalia...
And of course...
Virtual YouTubers...
A little about me is that...
I started out as a new maid...
In the maid cafe...
And you know...
I just had a teeny tiny little accident...
And I have...
Sorry...
Kind of died...
But I live on as a ghost...
Spreading my moe magic to everyone...
All over the world...
Um...
I never really got the chance...
To fully live my maid dreams...
And...
True...
I don't really mind being a ghost...
Especially since I love horror things so much...
That's true...
That's not true...
It's almost like a dream...
Being able to be an eternal maid...
You know?
That's so true...
Pass to me...
It was a genius...
So true...
Yeah...
This is a dream to be an eternal maid...
No...
Okay...
Virtual YouTubers...
What?
Why does it keep going to virtual?
I get that...
Sorry...
Okay...
I'm just gonna have to...
I can't pause...
I'm just gonna...
To let it go...
I'm just gonna have to let it go...
What do you mean what happened?
Okay...
Maybe we end it here...
Accident...
And I...
Ah...
No, no, no, hold on...
Wait...
Accident...
And I...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no...
Here...
...so much...
But...
It's almost like a dream...
Being able to be an eternal maid...
Yes...
Oh god...
I'm gonna...
I'm already dead...
I wanna die...
If I have my viewers and fans behind me...
I think I can continue on...
Mmm...
But not to the afterlife...
Not yet...
I'm in the afterlife...
What are you talking about?
I really want to become a VTuber...
So I can enjoy my ghostly life with everyone...
With really, really fun videos...
Oh...
I'm really not creepy...
I'm just super cute and goofy...
I promise...
I am creepy...
So...
There are a few VTubers I really look up to...
I'm so glad they didn't listen to this...
Kaguya Luna...
Hime Hina...
And Denno Shoujo Shiro...
I often also watch Natsuhiro Matsuri...
Oh yeah...
I did it at the time...
And I just love how cute and air-headed she can be...
And Hoshimachi Suisei...
Yeah...
She has such an amazing voice...
I just love listening to her music...
Yeah...
I used to actually perform as an idol in Akihabara...
So I have experience with singing and performing in front of an audience...
I think it can be similar to...
You know...
Having a good presence in videos as well...
I actually got to perform on the same stage that AKB48 performed on...
This is true...
So it was really, really, really exciting...
I'm actually still just...
I'm still studying Japanese...
But I'm able to hold a conversation since I learned a lot during my idol days...
I think I was like...
And I'm doing my best to study lots and lots and lots...
And my dream would be to collaborate with all the Japanese HoloLive members...
This is so...
Yes...
So I'd love to be able to communicate with everyone in Japan and all over the world...
But if it's all over the world, maybe I should pick up another language, huh?
Yeah, I never did that...
And I'm on my YouTube channel...
I did all my own filming and editing...
So I am confident that I would be able to deliver fun content at least three times a week...
And as I mentioned earlier, I really, really love horror...
Yes...
So I would love playing and reacting to horror games...
Yeah, yeah, yeah...
And even though I love it so much...
And I watch...
Horror movies and things every day...
Don't say it, Minto!
There's still a really big baby about it...
And sometimes I have to sleep with the lights on it...
That's not true...
That's not true, you guys!
That's never happened before ever!
I don't know, maybe people will find my screams entertaining, right?
You do!
And as for anime, I really enjoy all sorts of series...
Some of my favorite shows are Detective Conan and Konosuba...
And I am proud to say that I have seen every Detective Conan episode...
At the time, that was true!
I've written something, something...
Oh gosh, how many are now?
A thousand something, something!
But I listen to everyone about their favorite shows...
And what they're watching in the current season...
Yeah!
I also would really enjoy creating my own singing cover videos...
I think it would be so much fun to cover...
The Hololive songs...
And anime songs...
And idol songs...
Singing is definitely one of my passions...
And I'll make anything into a song...
Oh no, oh...
Like, you know, for example...
Oh no, I hate to...
Wait, I meant to take this out!
Kind of like that...
So I really hope I'm considered to be one of the next VTubers...
With the Hololive production team...
It would honestly be such a dream to be able to start this journey...
And I really think being able to reach out to so many people with my passions...
Would spark others to pursue their passions as well...
I'm a super duper passionate person...
And I just want to make others laugh and enjoy themselves...
And you know...
Since my life is cut short...
I want everyone to have a fun life...
Every day!
So thank you so much for watching...
And I look forward to hearing back from you...
Se no...
Moe Moe Kyun!
Thank you so much for watching!
Bye bye!
I'm so glad they didn't watch it...
I'm so glad...
I'm so glad they didn't...
I'm so glad they didn't watch it!
I'm so glad...
I'm...
I'm so glad they didn't watch it!
Oh...
Yeah, I never got a single...
Actually, I wonder...
If it's still on my channel...
Hmm...
Maybe you guys can watch it...
Well, no, I can't because I...
I can't because I had to take out the personal info...
So...
Yes, that was...
That was my...
Hello Live!
Audition 2020!
Oh no, it's not on my channel anymore...
Actually...
Actually, I don't even think this channel existed at the time...
No, wait!
It didn't!
It didn't exist because...
Because...
Um...
My...
I got the notification the other day that I was like...
Your channel's...
Five years old!
So...
No!
What did you guys...
Would you have hired me if you had...
Would you have hired me if you...
Um...
If you...
Had her in...
My audition!
No...
Yes, yes, no...
Yes, yes, yes, yes, no...
But obviously...
I understand...
You know...
I didn't have anything...
And that's why...
I...
That's why I started streaming!
Because I was just like...
Oh...
I will...
Become...
Become a streamer...
So that I can...
Actually...
I didn't even know if I would like streaming...
What if I hated it?
You just start immediately...
You know?
So...
Hmm...
Sorry, I'm eating also...
One of those...
Throat...
Syrups, so...
Sorry if I was like...
Oh wow...
While...
Talking...
Okay...
That's over with...
I shared with you...
Something very personal...
And...
Oh, despite...
Everything...
That happened...
I'm very happy...
Where I am...
So...
Hmm...
Very...
Grateful...
Thanks for the lore drop!
Yeah...
I don't think I've...
I don't think I...
Showed anybody that before...
Truly...
I think you guys are the...
First...
That's the first time I've ever shown anybody my...
Audition...
So...
Scary...
Ah...
Oh...
World premiere...
Not even...
No...
Well...
I...
Didn't tell anybody that I...
Wanted to be...
No...
None of my friends...
I never told them any...
About my channel...
At all...
So...
Um...
My friends didn't know until I went to heaven actually...
And...
I have people messaging me like...
Huh?
Is this you?
What?
And then...
You?
And I was like...
He he he...
Ah ha ha...
Ah
ha...
Ah ha...
Sorry...
Ah ha ha...
This you?
Crazy...
We got vids first...
I didn't know you were a virtual YouTuber...
I love virtual YouTuber...
Shall we keep singing?
Shall we keep singing singing?
Someone requested this earlier?
Uh...
Wait...
Now I have to go back...
Oh it's...
Wait...
Hold...
Where is it?
Eh...
Maybe here?
Yes.
One moment.
I got to get the lyrics.
It's been a long time since I've sung this song, so I hope I remember it.
How to sing it.
It might come back to me.
You know?
Like riding a bike.
It might come back to me.
Uh... Oh, shoot.
Oh, hiccups.
Sorry.
I hope I don't have hiccups now.
Oh, no.
Please, no.
Oh, gosh.
My computer is breaking.
Hold on.
I want to turn it down, but it's not.
Wait.
What?
Redo.
Restart.
Oh, sorry.
Hold on.
These lyrics are bad.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
One moment.
Ah, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Okay, one more time.
You
know what?
no question
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do The other hand,
the way I used to the cuirly now.
And the second one, the way I used to play it together reacting to somebody else.
When the mirror came, you might see the pandemic actually really rough awhile.
You have to stay, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk.
And this is the second one.
I'm going to go to the next one.
The lyrics also got weird on this version too.
Why?
Why can't I find lyrics at work?
I don't know.
Odoriko.
Odoriko, Odoriko.
Oh, the camera.
Staring at you.
Okay!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Oh, I have this song.
I said I would sing.
I don't know.
Maybe this version.
Let's listen to it.
Hold on.
Let me listen to it real quick.
Let's see if it sounds good.
Oh, it sounds fine, I think.
Okay, so, oh my gosh, it sounds like an old-timey karaoke.
This is so good.
It sounds old-timey.
Whenever sang my songs On the stage, on my own Whenever said my words Wishing they would be heard I saw you smiling at me I saw you smiling at me Was it real or just my fantasy You'd always be there in the corner Of this tiny little bar My last night here for you Same old songs,
just once more My last night here with you Maybe yes, maybe no I kind of liked it your way How you shyly placed your eyes on me Oh, did you ever know That I had mine on you Darling, so there you are With that look on your face As if you're never hurt As if you're never down Shall I be the one for you Who pinches you softly But sure If frown is shown then I will know that You are no dream
Don't get so close, I'm shy!
So let me come to you.
Close as I wanna be.
Close enough for me.
To feel your heart beating fast.
And stay there as I whisper.
How I loved your peaceful eyes on me.
And did you ever know that I had mine on you?
Darling, so share with me.
Your love if you have enough.
Your tears if you're holding back.
Or pain if that's what it is.
How can I let you...
In the dress and love.
Just reach me out then.
You will know that you are no dreamer.
Darling, so there you are.
With that look on your face.
As if you're never hurt.
As if you're never down.
Shall I be the one for you?
Who pinches you softly by shore.
You will know that you are no dreamer.
Yay!
That was eyes on me.
Sorry.
I didn't expect to zoom in.
Hold on.
Let me turn off the camera.
I can't look at it.
I get too shy.
Because it feels so close.
And then I sing a song like that.
And it feels... It feels... It feels... Too... Too... Too... Too intimate, you know?
Okay.
We're normal?
We're fine.
We're normal.
Are you guys excited?
Just two more songs until the announcement.
Just two more.
What should we sing?
Hmm...
I had some songs written, but I'm feeling kind of...
Maybe... I'll sing this one.
If I can remember how to sing it.
Oh gosh.
I don't want to mess it up though.
I have no confidence.
Wait.
Actually, is there even...
Uh...
Maybe.
I don't think I've ever sung this song before, so...
Wait, let me make sure this... What?
I could have sworn that there was a...
Carol... Not caro-fun.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'll try...
Wait, hold on.
Let me hear it real quick.
I'm listening.
I'm not just sitting here bopping my head to nothing.
Ah...
Okay,
I think I remember it.
It's summer, so we have to sing this song.
Wait, let me start over.
Sorry.
Unless You were What has to do.
I think I can remember the shadow of the night.
I've been looking for the light that summer.
I've been looking for the light that I've ever been.
I'm not going to be a little.
Sayonara, I wrote a letter in your eyes.
This is the second one.
Oh, I love you.
I can't forget it.
But if it's winter...
This
is my ass.
Sorry.
I'm... I'm swapping.
Oh, I can't read that.
Don't forget it.
I'm so sorry.
But I'm so sorry.
And this is the first sentence.
And this is the second sentence.
In the fall.
Oh, I love you.
Sorry.
I can't be able to forget, but...
In the next summer, we will be here again.
Remember summer days.
Oh, I love you.
Summer days
Do you guys see my heart is sparkling?
Oh!
Sorry.
Wait.
Okay.
Good.
I stopped it in time.
You can see it sparkling.
Can't you see?
Hmm.
That was Remember Summer Days.
Sorry.
I messed it up a little bit.
Remember Summer Days.
Well, Summer had to sing Summer Days, right?
What's another summer song we can think of?
Ah...
Summer.
Wait.
Oh, I had one.
Oh, I think I forgot to write it down.
Oh, it even had... Oh, wait.
I remember it.
No, I don't.
Wait.
Oh, I had another summer song.
I don't remember it.
I know one though.
I know one that I will sing.
This one I don't think I've also ever sung before.
Okay.
I sing.
Kind of relevant.
Since I'm five years old now.
Wait.
Hello?
Oh.
I've seen the world.
Done it all.
Had my cake.
Now.
Oh, shoot.
Diamonds.
Wait.
Hold on.
I don't...
How the hell...
Wait.
Why am I...
Sorry.
I think I'm still nervous from...
Hold on.
Let me listen to it real quick.
Why am I...
I literally was singing this song earlier.
Why am I not remembering how it goes now?
I've done it all.
Had my cake.
Now.
Diamonds.
Okay, okay, okay.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
It's karaoke.
It's not serious.
I've seen the world.
Done it all.
Had my cake now.
Diamonds.
Brilliant.
And Bel Air now.
Hot summer nights.
Mid July.
When you and I were forever wild.
The crazy days.
The city lights.
The way you'd play with me like a child.
Will you still love me when I'm no longer young and beautiful?
Will you still love me when I got nothing but my aching soul?
I know you will.
I know that you will.
Will you still love me when I'm no longer beautiful?
I've seen the world.
Lit it up.
As my stage now.
Channeling angels.
In the new age now.
Am I saying this right or wrong?
Hot summer days.
Rock and roll.
The way you will.
The way you'd play for me at your show.
And all the ways I got to know.
Your pretty face.
An electric soul.
Will you still love me when I'm no longer young and beautiful?
Will you still beautiful?
Will you still love me when I got nothing but my aching soul?
I know you will.
I know that you will.
Will, will you still love me when I'm no longer beautiful?
Dear Lord, when I get to heaven, please let me bring my cat.
When he comes, tell me that you'll let him.
Father, tell me that you can.
Oh, that grace, oh, that body, oh, that face makes me wanna party.
He's like, my son, like diamonds.
Sorry.
Will you still love me when I'm no longer young and beautiful?
Will you still love me when I've got nothing but my aching soul?
I know I want my cat with me.
I don't need no man.
But I don't wanna think about me talking about my cat's body and face.
I'm no longer beautiful.
Will you still love me when I'm no longer beautiful?
Will you still love me when I'm not young and beautiful?
Luckily for you guys, I'm Forever 19, no matter what you heard earlier.
Forever 19, baby!
Yippee!
Oh
man, beautiful.
I think it's announcement time.
I'm scared.
Um...
Oh, let me turn the camera off.
Ah, it was too late.
Are you guys ready?
Ready,
ready, ready, ready, ready.
Ready, ready, ready, ready, ready.
Okay, I don't have anything special to play.
So it's just gonna be me counting down, okay?
I don't have anything...
Special, so...
It's just...
It'll be me still.
Okay, so...
Announcement time, everybody!
Announcement!
Everybody!
Everybody, come in to hear the announcement!
Everybody, get in here!
Get in here!
Hear ye, hear ye!
I'm getting married?
Yes, you probably know.
Well, that announcement was already made, sorry.
No, just kidding.
I'm getting married.
Hear ye!
My first...
Official...
New outfit!
Woooo!
Wah-wah-wah-wah-wah!
Wah-wah-wah-wah-wah-wah!
Um...
It...
You're probably like...
Uh, Minto, there's no date.
Well, um...
Uh...
So there was some delays that happened.
But I still wanted to make the announcement because otherwise I had nothing today!
I had nothing!
So...
Um...
New outfit!
It will be August though!
August, August!
Meow!
Let me show you the full silhouette!
Wait...
3, 2, 1...
Butt...
Oh...
Oh!
Oh, shoot!
I forgot to resize it!
Okay, well...
One moment...
Wait, one...
One second, let me resize it!
Okay...okay...3, 2, 1, ba-boom...and you probably noticed...there's a hashtag...hashtag...mintotaku!
So I guess if you want to try and...I mean...if you...you don't have to.
If you want to try and guess, you can, but you don't have to.
Mintotaku!
New outfit!
Next month!
Yippee!
So...um...I probably will put up like a...I probably will put up like a...waiting room...that is a tentative date.
It will be a little while, so...sorry, it's not gonna be like next week or anything...so...um...just wait a little bit, but I...I...I just wanted to...
Announce it early!
so...yeah!
And that's also why i wore long hair today!
Because, as you can see, my hair is long...and...um...mmmmmmmmm...mMMMM!
I already tell some details.
Hummah hummah.
Hummah hummah hummah.
Hmmmm.
So yeah, it's my first ever actual... I mean...
I guess you could count like how I look now as a new outfit.
But because I went from 1.0 to 2.0 into this outfit.
But as like a whole brand new...
Original... on this own outfit.
This is the first ever.
So I'm very excited.
I'm so excited.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yippee!
That's the announcement!
Exciting, exciting, exciting!
It only took five years!
It only took five years for me to change clothes!
Ah, yeah, baby.
I'll stick it up here.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah.
I guess we can sing a few more songs.
Outfit 3 in 2030?
Hey.
I...
I feel like it might be that with how...
Busy...
Celia Papa is.
Yes.
Isn't it better though?
To...
Kind of space things out?
Let things simmer a bit?
No!
Let them let...
You get an outfit and then you...
You...
You kind of wait on it!
You use it!
And then...
You...
I don't know.
Next year, I'll get another outfit.
So...
Hmm...
Exciting!
Exciting, exciting, exciting, exciting, exciting.
Um...
What should we sing next?
Hold on.
Let me do my throat spray real quick.
Come...
My throat...
Has been...
It doesn't...
Sound...
End up sounding bad, but it does start to hurt after a while, so...
Um...
Suki akari?
Oh, I think I know that one actually.
Wait, hold on.
I think I do know that one.
Oh!
Yeah, darker than black!
Oh my gosh!
I used to listen to this song all the time.
Do I remember it still?
Hold on.
Let me listen to it real quick.
I might remember it.
Gosh...
Boomer?
Requesting darker than black?
Yeah, eh...
Oh...
Sorry.
I'm... I'm making sure I know it.
Oh my gosh...
Oh, I used to listen to this song so often.
Okay, let me try singing it.
Sorry if it's scoff.
I'm sorry, I'm remembering it at the same time.
Sorry, I'm remembering it at the same time.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I was calling the name.
I believed in this light.
In the middle of the night, I don't think there's any time.
There isn't a day, I don't think about it.
That
part very well, sorry.
In
the middle of the night,
I call my name.
I'm going to go to Hawaii, this time.
I'm going to go to Hawaii.
I've been looking for my future.
Little... Little fish?
What?
I
just realized, sorry guys.
Oh my gosh.
Good song, wow.
What a great recommendation!
Oh my gosh.
Like I said, I haven't heard that song in so long.
Probably like over 10 years.
I can't believe I still remember it.
It's kind of like those things, you know?
Old people can't remember much.
But they can still remember music.
They hear something and it brings back everything.
You know?
Happy 5 years!
Thank you!
Can you sing Do You Remember Love?
I can.
Actually...
There's another song I want to sing too.
Sorry, I'm gonna cue it up.
But I will sing Do You Remember Love?
Love...
Uhm...
Ah!
It's been so long!
I feel like there's...
I can't stop thinking of songs that I want to sing.
Well, let me just actually write it down.
Uhm...
Um, um, um, um, um, um...
What was I gonna say?
Oh...
There we go, I remember it.
Okay.
Do You Remember Love?
Let me listen to this karaoke.
Okay, see if it's good.
Sorry, it was so loud in my ear.
Holy cow, this is an official one.
I don't want to sing that because I will probably get in trouble.
I don't...that's not the song.
That's not the song.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, there's Caitlin Myers' version.
Her English version.
I love Caitlin.
She's so sweet.
I miss Caitlin.
I miss Caitlin of Final Fantasy.
You know what?
If it gets taken down, it gets taken down.
Smack Cross Frontier's final live this weekend.
I know, because Phoebe's going.
Thank you.
I'm currently here for the first time.
Let's go!
There's a few words.
I'm still here.
I'm still here for the first time.
And we are back.
The in-person, this is the first sentence.
I love you so...
A
little pause... and we are back.
And this is the second one.
The world is now...
Do you remember the moment that I saw the moment that I saw the moment?
I love you so.
Does it matter if we place our hands together?
Does it matter when we touch our eyes?
Do you remember me?
When my hand and hand came together...
It was the first time I loved it...
I love you so...
I'm not a place.
You're right, so...
Yay!
That was I Oboete Imashuka, aka do you remember love.
I hope that was the one you were talking about.
Now that I think about it... I don't know any other do you remember love... Ah, wait, let me put it in.
Set list... I Oboete Imashuka...
Actually, you know how in my audition talk... It's not really an audition video... In my audition talk sound... How I... I said I was an idol a little bit, right?
And... Just for a little bit.
It wasn't very long, to be honest.
And... I think I said years in the video and then I was listening back to it.
I was like, did I mean to put that?
Because it's not accurate.
But anyway... Um... Well, this song was one of the songs I used to sing.
I used to sing... In... During my stages and then... During the parts where it was just like... There's the Oboete Imashuka... Me to Mega... Ureate At Toki... They're saying like... When her eyes met... With me and so I would like... Go up to somebody in the audience... And I would be like... Close,
close, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep...
When I close up to them, with like making eye contact.
And then the other part is...
Um...
Wait, maybe I got the lyrics wrong.
Wait, but the te-to-te part with the hands.
I would go up to somebody and I would like, like, take their hand.
My fan saw was off the charts.
Too bad.
Too bad you guys can't, you know.
I can't jump through your screen.
You guys can't grab a ghost and go right through, you know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was so fun.
That was good.
I think I know what I want to say next, if that's okay.
But I actually...
I have to...
Go to the bathroom.
I have to go to the little ghosty's room.
Is that okay?
Baby in VR?
Wait, that would be so fun if I...
Wait, if I did a concert in VR...
And like, had people in the audience?
But...
How...
How would I get you guys to shut up?
Imagine someone's just yapping the entire time.
How would I make it so that you guys can't talk?
Hmm...
Okay, I'll be right back.
Hold on, let me give you some music.
Wait, sorry, I want to get more tea too.
I'll be right back.
Again.
Sorry.
I want more tea.
Wait a second.
What is my face?
I look so perverted.
What the hell?
That was weird.
Actually, I'm just going to do this with these atlas.
Sorry.
I will put the full one in case...
Well, you might have seen it.
All right.
Actually, it looks like now it's like...
Announcement!
Okay, I'll just do this.
Yeah!
Aren't you though?
Yeah, but...
But it's...
But...
But it's embarrassing when you say it out loud, no?
That's why we use the word freaky here.
Instead.
We don't even...
How
embarrassed.
A little freaky ghost.
That's me!
Decision to make that a new emote.
What's that face?
And I want to thank again also everybody too.
Who is donating via Streamlabs.
I do see your donors and I'm seeing them.
Especially you.
Irish...
Wrist...
Watch...
Bye, Roebuck.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much.
What the hell?
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Okay.
I have another song I want to sing.
It's another little bit of a...
Slow song.
But I love Blue Archive.
Let me get the...
Lyrics for me.
Then I want to go back to singing English songs.
Blue Archive.
You guys are already guessing it.
He he.
Oh, loud.
Sorry.
No.
Hey.
Jason.
Thank you.
Hey.
This is the second one.
To be continued...
I think that this song is composed by the same person that composed my opening intro music.
It's Kiyo-san!
And we are back, slowly, slowly, slowly, slowly.
Even if we are not here,
we are back.
We believe that the future will be the future.
I will......
Sorry for all the scuff tonight.
It's fine.
It's fine!
That was 13.
Yumeji no Hana.
Yumeji no Hana from Blue Aka.
Yay!
What should we sing next?
Oh wait!
There was one other song that I wanted to sing.
One other Japanese song.
Sorry, I forgot.
And now so I will...
Sing it.
Pop off my head...
net8...6
When you are from us, you appear so great...
I can't believe that you all are loved...
I'm always the one out...
well,
we've got the truth and we're getting started.
This goes down to a pair of two special ghosts.
I don't know if you're watching, but if you are...
I'm so sorry.
What's the first one?
I'll never forget.
I'm so sorry.
If you're in a ring, I'll be like a star.
It's a single one.
The blood of the sun is the first time of the spring.
This is the second one.
We'll see.
I will be the first sentence.
And this is the last sentence.
And this is the second sentence.
I will not be the first sentence.
Sorry.
Maybe I shouldn't have sung it.
That was...
A song that recently has been very, very close to my heart.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Throat is still feeling good, so I can keep going, I think.
We're just a couple more songs, and...
What should we sing?
English song now.
English song, English song, English song.
Um...
Actually...
I wanna...
I watched the Beauty and the Beast live action not too long ago.
And I watched it because...
There... Oh, I forgot to turn off the camera, sorry.
There's a... There is... There's a song.
What song is it that is so worth it?
And...
I tried singing it during that karaoke...
Or not during... Sorry, not the karaoke.
During that stream.
It was a... It was a... It was a...
What do you call...
A...
Member stream.
So...
Um...
It was...
Not...
You know...
A public stream.
But I tried singing it and I...
It's so embarrassing.
I couldn't hit the notes because...
Because...
Because my voice was so bad and now I want a...
I want a revenge.
I want a revenge!
So I will try...
What if I can't hit it again though?
That would be so embarrassing.
That would be so embarrassing!
But I'll try it.
I'm nervous.
Because I...
Got it last time.
I was the one who had it all.
I was the master of my fate.
I never needed anybody in my life.
I learned the truth too late.
I'll never shake away the pain.
I close my eyes but she's still there.
I let her steal into my melancholy heart.
It's more than I can bear.
Now I know she'll never leave me.
Even as she runs away.
She will still torment me.
Call me.
Hurt me.
Move me.
Come what may.
Wasting in my lonely tower.
Waiting by an open door.
I'll fool myself.
She'll walk right in.
And be with me forevermore.
I rage against the trials of love.
I curse the fading of the light.
Though she's already flown so far beyond my reach.
She's never out of sight.
Now I know she'll never leave me.
Even as she fades to view.
She will still inspire me.
Be a part of everything I do.
We sing in my lonely tower.
Waiting by an open door.
I'll flow myself, she'll walk right in.
And as the long, long nights begin.
I'll think of all that might have been.
Waiting here forever.
Ever...more...
Maybe I should end it on that.
No, let's end it on something less... Oh my gosh.
Bring back yearning.
Sorry.
I love when men yearn.
It's so good.
Anyway.
Oh!
So happy!
What's a fun song we can end it on?
It's time for Mickey Mouse music.
Sorry.
No, I'm not going to do break stuff.
Oh my gosh.
Not with my throat.
It's just getting better.
Snake eater?
The Hilah Evergarden song.
Oh gosh, what was that one?
From the star?
Oh, I can sing that one.
But I...
Wait, I think I do actually.
Wait.
What was the one from Violet Evergarden?
Oh my gosh, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna...
What was the one from Violet Evergarden?
I will do a snake eater.
Don't worry.
Here, I'll write it down.
Wait, but I was only gonna do one song.
I do a snake eater every time.
I'm trying to remember what that song was from.
Hold on.
I'm gonna look it up because it...
Oh wait.
Letter, right?
That song.
That's such a sad song though.
I don't want to end it on that.
Okay, I'll do two songs.
We'll do Letter next time.
This time, we do this.
What a thrill.
With darkness and silence through the night.
I'm searching and I'll melt into you.
What a fear in my heart.
But you're so supreme.
I give my life, not for honor, but for you.
In my time, there'll be no one else.
Crime is the way I fly to you.
I'm still in a dream.
Snake eater.
Some day, you go through the rain.
And some day, you feed on a tree frog.
This ordeal, the trial to survive.
I give my life, not for the day, you wrap your life.
And some day, you'll see the light.
I give my life, not for
the rest of you.
I give my life, not for the day.
I'm still in a dream.
Snake Eater.
Okay, the people requested it.
Ah, how, who am I to not give the people what they want?
Ah...
A little pause...
and we are back.
Bawlerless...! !MIND
!?Bawlerline Mines.
Mines  Mines
For your sake, for your future, Even if you're not alone, I want to love you.
I
want to be loved,
I'll be back.
Ikenai, borderline.
Yay!
Yay, yay, yay.
Well, it's just about the last song.
And, you know, it's been a very tumultuous week.
Very tumultuous couple of weeks for me since I've known.
You know, I found out about everything at Toho Lost Word.
Like, right before the Lost Word Live.
And, you know...
And the staff was only found out a couple days before that.
So, you know, they told us pretty much as soon as they could tell us how bad it was.
So, it was, um...
Pretty stressful.
I...
Um...
You know...
I'm still trying to figure out what I want to do from here on out.
But I can tell you that I will keep going at the very least.
And I, you know...
I tweeted that I really...
I really...
That...
And I mean to...
I really meant to that I...
Um...
Wouldn't be able to keep going forward without you guys.
So...
Thank you so, so much.
And...
I really love...
Each and every one of you.
I really love the community...
That we have here.
And I hope that, you know...
I...
And I feel...
I feel like any time I see someone new come in, they always say that...
You guys are very welcoming.
And...
You guys, um...
Are always so kind, and...
Um...
Yeah...
I'm...
I'm really, really grateful.
I'm really, really happy that...
We...
We're able to...
Build something so awesome...
In these five years.
And...
I know...
There's still names that I see...
From...
2020.
Which is so crazy!
So absolutely insane!
And then I see new names almost every day as well.
And that's just really exciting.
Um...
And I'm just really, really grateful.
You know, I...
I can't...
I...
I can't ever stop saying how grateful I am, truly.
Um...
Yeah...
So...
Thank you, guys.
Back to when...
Back when I used to play...
Tetrio with everybody!
And now...
Gosh!
Whatever...
We used to watch animal cams.
I...
I still think very fondly on those days.
And I...
You know, I...
I...
Uh...
I'll never forget my channel almost getting deleted over the frickin' BBC.
I once watched a...
I once watched a monkey spy cam video once and my channel almost got taken down.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Totank!
VVC!
I'll never forgive them!
Ha ha ha ha!
Um...
I...
I guess I thought it was too much like Twitch or something that you could just watch whatever you want.
Ha ha ha ha!
I...
Actually...
I think that strike might finally be gone from my channel.
When I came back last year, it was still there.
It was.
It...
Actually, I don't see it anymore.
I think it finally disappeared.
I think I'm finally in the clear!
Ha ha ha!
Oh wait, not last year.
The year before, you know.
You know what I mean.
But yeah...
Um...
Hmm...
I mean...
I wouldn't say I'm very...
Resilient.
I'm actually, you know, you guys know I'm kind of a crybaby.
And I...
I...
I take...
Many things to heart.
Which is what you're not supposed to do.
When you...
Are...
An...
Internet figure.
Ha ha ha!
But...
Um...
You know...
What am I gonna do?
Die?
Bleh!
Ha ha ha!
So...
I'll just keep doing my best.
And...
I want...
You know...
I...
I do want to...
Well, not...
I...
A lot of people...
A lot of people were commenting things.
Like, you've done so much, Minto.
You don't need a company.
You have your fans.
You have everything like that.
And...
I...
While...
They're correct, obviously.
They're...
Everybody is correct saying that.
There's something so...
You know...
Don't think about how valuable it is to have...
Um...
People working...
For you.
Or with you.
That have good connections.
And can help you do things.
And...
Help you meet...
New companies.
And things like that.
And...
I...
I just want to be able to be...
Uh...
You know, someone that you can...
Type of streamer.
A VTuber.
Your O-shi, if I am.
Someone that you can be like...
My O-shi...
She did that really cool thing!
And...
Someone that you can be like...
Oh my God...
She is...
Working with this company.
Or she is...
Doing this thing.
Or that thing.
Doing this concert.
Or whatever.
I want to be, you know...
Something like...
I want to be someone that you can... kind of... kind of gloat about.
Someone who does cool things.
But, you know, I obviously still have fun and I'm very happy to do just what I'm doing now.
But I, you know, always... I don't want to be stagnant.
And, you know...
We'll see what happens in the future.
Obviously.
It's been really stressful because everything has been in such limbo for the past couple of weeks.
For me, just not knowing.
When things change so fast, something would be told to me.
And then the next day, something else would be told to me.
And I would just be like, I... I can't... I can't follow anymore.
But, you know, you guys have supported me through...
Every step and so.
Every step.
2020 to now.
Five years.
Resilient like a roach?
Ew!
Don't bring that...
Negative energy into here!
And, you know, in my...
In my audition...
I said I wanted to be...
You know...
Since I'm...
Since I'm dead.
Since I didn't get to live my life to the fullest.
I want to be...
Someone that can help you.
You know.
You know, have lots of fun in your...
Daily lives.
So...
That...
Message has never changed for me.
And so...
I hope that I can keep being your...
Your...
Spooky ghost maid!
Um...
For much, much longer.
Until you don't want me anymore.
Will you still love me...
When I'm no younger...
Wait...
Young...
No...
Wait...
What's the word?
Is this...
Wait...
No...
Oh...
Longer!
I said younger!
No...
Forever 19!
I think I changed it...
Because you know how the joke is Forever 17?
And I was like...
Well, 19 has the teen in it.
You know, like...
To make it seem like it's...
Forever...
17...
But...
Forever 19...
I can still play Eroge.
And that's literally the only reason why it's Forever 7...
Not 7...
It's Forever 19.
So that...
So that I could still play Eroge and not get in trouble.
That's literally it!
It's always been that way from the beginning!
Yeah...
Oh, thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I don't want to be...
I don't want you guys to have to feel like you cheer me up!
You guys...
You're so funny!
I'm always laughing every day!
I want to be the one to cheer you guys up if you need it!
You guys are always making me laugh with your comments and everything!
That was so much fun!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
So...
Well, I'm glad we can have fun here!
And I hope you have fun!
I hope so!
I hope that my streams are at least a little entertaining!
Shall we send it off in a classic...
Classic Minky style?
Classic Minky style!
How I've sent it off...
How I used to send it off every stream!
Back in the day!
I'm so good!
I'm so
good!
Let's go!
FC and Thangs sleeping in your bed...
Can you tell me what he said?
Yeah!
An invisible man...
...sleepin' in your bed Ow!
Let me tell you something...
Ow!
Yeah!
Busting!
Makes you feel good...
Yeah!
The
pause, pause, pause, pause, pause it makes me feel good!
Senna!
Freaky ghost maid!
Freaky ghost man!
Freaky man, baby!
Let me sleep in your bed.
And let me tell you something.
Sleeping makes me feel good.
I ain't no sleep.
I'm afraid of no bed.
Speaking
close, bad!
Busting, busting, busting, busting, vida sin accident,i'm up.
It must make me feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feels good!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Thank you guys so much for five years!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you guys!
I really, really appreciate it!
And I'll keep working hard!
And, um, look forward to the new outfit!
Next one!
Yeah!
I will see you guys later!
Feel good.
Oh.
Oh, I thought that was an M.
I miscalculated.
Makes me feel good.
Feel good!
I
want to do a close-up for Bye-Bye.
For Bye-Bye, I want to do a close-up.
Please?
Wait, hold on.
I know this.
Thank you!
I hope you enjoyed your time at my maid cafe today!
And I hope to see you again!
Another day!